this video is sponsored by skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description
get their first two months free this is
the ti europe one of the four
largest ships in the world and here's a
banana for scale
at 380 meters long or 1200 feet
it's 41 percent longer than the titanic
but still shorter than titanic in this
business
efficiency is everything and every
dollar
counts a ship made with twice the steel
has much more than twice the capacity
with roughly the same
size crew bigger boats therefore cost
only a little bit more and yet make a
lot more money
so here we are with super tankers that
can hold
3 million barrels of oil which at
today's going price
makes the ti europe a 174
million dollar target for pirates last
year an attack was reported every other
day
in some of the busiest most
well-patrolled routes
like the gulf of aden the singapore
strait and the coast of malaysia
but these are not parrot-wearing
sword-carrying outlaws
today's pirates operate a carefully
planned well-executed business
with investors a stock market chain of
command
and experienced negotiators all without
the help of linkedin
and with profit margins of over 30
percent even
apple should be jealous
somalia is by almost every metric one of
the hardest places to live
on earth its now three decade long civil
war
has not only led to drought and famine
but also left the country without a
unified central government
to the north are the independent but
unrecognized states of somaliland and
pontland
in the south control is split between
the federal government based in the
capital
mogadishu and large terrorist factions
this makes building infrastructure like
schools and hospitals
extremely difficult which in turn makes
building a formal economy
nearly impossible the result is a
55-year life expectancy
one of the lowest in the world and a gdp
that makes ghana and madagascar
look rich while next door ethiopia makes
money growing coffee potatoes and
cereals
somalia is not so lucky only 1.8 percent
of its land is arable
compared to half of india or 34
of germany its two climates are hot
and really hot but it does have one
thing going for it
the longest coastline of any country in
africa
fishing should be a huge source of
income but
you guessed it there's a catch foreign
companies
noticed the country seemed a little
preoccupied at the moment
and probably wouldn't notice if they
dumped toxic waste in its waters
killing thousands of fish in the process
those that survived are now caught
illegally by foreign fishermen
who steal 300 million dollars worth
every year
leaving somalia with only a small share
of its own tuna
so just to recap somalis are given
little education
face a constant threat of violence have
nearly zero health care
and a per capita gdp of keeps growing
104 or 28 cents
per person per day the average ransom
on the other hand is 2.7 million so
piracy is not exactly a tough sell
it all begins by identifying a target
the ideal victim comes from a rich
country is traveling slowly
and near the coast or in the case of
luxury cruise ship
star breeze which was attacked in 2005
all three the next step is financing
a single attack may cost 30 thousand
dollars up front
which is already a lot but especially
in somalia so the risk is usually spread
between
three to five investors who buy shares
in an informal stock market
now comes the attack with one large
mothership
anywhere between 4 and 20 pirates follow
their target
up to 800 miles off the coast once they
get close
they switch to one or two small chaser
boats and use ropen ladders to board the
ship
of course the crew is trying to speed up
or change
directions and fight back but they also
know they're no match for the ak-47s
rocket launchers and desperation of the
pirates
the crew is gathered together and their
communications destroyed
making the ship go dark the next step
depends on their business model in areas
like southeast asia
the goal is often stealing oil selling
it to anyone smart enough not to ask
why it's so cheap but here in somalia
pirates rarely touch the cargo the crew
is
by far the most valuable thing on board
they steer the ship to a nearby port
where the most
tense part of the operation begins with
only one buyer
and one seller almost none of the rules
of a normal negotiation
apply neither party has all the
information
and both have great incentive to lie the
owner of the ship
wants to appear poor driving down the
ransom
the pirates meanwhile need to seem rash
enough to deliver on their threats
and yet patient enough to wait for a
deal because
the clock is ticking as time goes on the
value of the ship and its cargo
goes down and the average ransom
generally goes
up talks therefore can last 3 4
500 days all spoken through a translator
often with several different negotiators
if the owner has kidnapping
and ransom insurance negotiations are
made by a professional
who reduces the chance of death from
nine percent to just
two but companies aren't allowed to say
they have insurance
in fact many corporate travelers don't
know they have k
r insurance if they did it would be
invalidated
because of the incentives an agreement
is almost always
reached pirates bring the crew up to the
top deck
confirming their safety and then a
helicopter flies overhead
and drops a waterproof container full of
cash
finally comes a pirate's favorite job
accounting
first investors get their guaranteed cut
of at least
30 percent the port who looked the other
way while they parked the ship
gets five to ten percent and the rest is
split between the attackers with a bonus
of around ten thousand dollars for being
first to board the ship
this scenario plays out hundreds of
times a year
and cost shipping companies a total of
4.9 to 8.3 billion dollars a year
including security and insurance even
just speeding up from 13
to 18 knots costs an extra
fuel per ship per day and those costs
are passed on to you and me
we all pay a hidden piracy tax so
what can be done the obvious answer is
fighting back
nato's operation ocean shield greatly
reduced attacks from 2009 to 16 by
patrolling dangerous waters
and many shippers now hire private
security companies to fill that role
but this creates a free rider problem
other companies and countries
benefit from that security without
paying for it themselves
likewise everyone would be better off if
no one paid ransoms
but it's always in each company's best
interest to pay them
all of these solutions reduce piracy but
none of them
solve it for 30 to 75 000
per attack there will always be someone
willing to take that risk
no matter how high it becomes the only
real solution
is economic giving pirates alternative
ways to make money
rebuilding a country like somalia is a
major
undertaking but giving locals new skills
and
new opportunities really is the
long-term
solution and that reminds me of a
certain sponsor of today's video
you guessed it skillshare what a
coincidence
my new favorite skillshare class is
youtuber thomasfrank's tips
on how to be more productive he does a
really good job of going into detail
and really focusing on how you can apply
the different apps
and techniques to the specific way that
you work or study
if like me you're interested in business
and economics
you should take a class like how the
stock market works by youtuber business
casual
it's no secret that youtube comments
kind of just get lost in the void
and that's kind of what i like about
skillshare you can directly
ask questions and get help from the
instructor
so whatever you're interested in art
photography
app development animation hey that's my
class
go try skillshare for free for two whole
months by using the link
in the description thanks to you and
thanks to skillshare